el agua se extiende hasta donde alcanza
la vista en el sur de Pakistán cientos
de hectáreas de Campos y pueblos se
encuentran bajo este lago
Tas Lima no se ha ido de su pueblo
parcialmente sumergido
lleva tres semanas viviendo rodeada de
esta agua insalubre
[Música]
Sabemos que esta agua está sucia pero no
tenemos otra opción Aunque usemos jabón
para lavar la ropa y la sequemos al sol
Sigue estando sucia bebemos esta agua
lavamos nuestros platos con ella nos
bañamos con ella también nos da miedo
venir aquí porque hay insectos y
serpientes en el agua incluso hemos
tenido que matar algunos de ellos
esta madre de ocho hijos perdió su casa
por las devastadoras inundaciones
la familia se tuvo que refugiar en la
cima de una colina del pueblo no hay
ninguna sombra que los proteja del sol
[Música]
bajo este Refugio improvisado tras Lima
cuida a su bebé nacido hace unos 20 días
antes de que empezaran las inundaciones
Este es mi hijo miren cómo está su piel
[Música]
el grupo que extraño que sí
es por el agua
para ver a un médico hay que tomar una
Barca hasta Tierra Firme pero tras clima
no tiene recursos para pagar el trayecto
antes de las inundaciones habían
comadronas que venían a nuestro pueblo
nos orientaban sobre cómo cuidar a
nuestro bebé y cómo bañarnos y cuidar
después del parto pero ahora como todas
las carreteras están inundadas Ya no
pueden venir aquí y no tenemos a nadie
que nos guíe en las ciudades que no
fueron afectados por las aguas en los
campamentos de emergencias las
condiciones de vida de las mujeres no
son las mejores
las autoridades locales distribuyeron
tiendas de campaña pero no la
suficientes para los cientos de familias
que han encontrado Refugio aquí
Shakira sueña con poder volver a su
pueblo que sigue bajo el agua la vida
cotidiana aquí es difícil no hay
instalaciones sanitarias Este es el baño
que tenemos es de tela y no sirve para
nada no hay sistema de desagüe no hay
ningún agujero si lo usamos una vez el
suelo se ensucia y ya no se puede volver
a usar no tenemos los recursos
necesarios para construir un baño de
verdad ni para construir un sistema de
desagüe
ven estos arbustos tenemos que
escondernos aquí al aire libre para
hacer nuestras necesidades si pasa
alguien por ahí tenemos que parar y
vestirnos rápidamente
este lugar es utilizado tanto por
hombres como por mujeres
Aquí también pasta el ganado por lo que
los pastores suelen estar aquí
es como vivimos no tenemos otra opción
la vida se organiza al aire libre y en
condiciones de hacinamiento a las que
estas familias de origen tradicional y
conservador no están acostumbradas
[Aplausos]
todos los días las distribuciones de
agua y alimentos suelen ser caóticas y
las mujeres que se atreven a ir a menudo
parten con las manos vacías
es muy difícil vivir aquí porque hay
hombres que pasan y miran dentro de
nuestras tiendas no hay privacidad no
enviamos a nuestros hijos ni a las
mujeres jóvenes de nuestra familia
cuando es distribuciones de alimentos
porque tenemos miedo de que los
secuestran
y ella eso ya ha pasado aquí
recientemente
una ambulancia con un equipo médico a
bordo se dirige a un campamento de
emergencia
anhela Abdul Karim va cada semana para
examinar a las mujeres Estas mujeres
provienen de zonas Rurales son bastante
conservadoras no pueden hablar de sus
problemas médicos con médicos hombres
especialmente si están embarazadas o
tienen problemas ginecológicos se siente
mucho más cómodas con una mujer
en esta orilla decenas de familias han
encontrado Refugio muchas mujeres están
embarazadas
a la llegada de anila ya hay algunas
pacientes esperándola
tiene siete meses de embarazo Qué
problemas ha tenido desde su última
cesárea tuve varios abortos espontáneos
A los cuantos meses ocurrieron cuatro o
cinco meses qué le ocurre en este
momento tengo mucho dolor son como
calambres en el estómago sí tienen
náuseas Sí pero también me siento muy
débil manicomio no tengo que comer mi
marido trabaja en una granja pero se
inundó y perdió su trabajo
en pocos minutos llegan mujeres de todas
las edades viven en condiciones
sanitarias muy precarias no tienen baños
ni agua potable utilizan ropa sucia
cuando tienen la menstruación y Eso
provoca muchas infecciones
millones de mujeres se encuentran en
situación de precariedad extrema
son más vulnerables que nunca
[Música]